viens vous êtes prête j'ai qu'un grand
mère de christian vadim s'appelait
ardilouze et benoît haute de verdun
entendu ça la semaine dernière dans
l'émission et il m'a envoyé un mail avec
une idée d'interviews qui s'appelle
l'ardilouse
bon l'ardilouse c'est que les trucs de
luz votre pire passage télé à part suis
là ce soir c'était bon mais c'était le
dernier
très bien votre pire cuite jamais en
danger une phobie
du vomi donc jamais je bois fait mal
assez bien sa chance
et tu as été quand la champagne ce soir
et vous je vous demande pas c'était la
veille de la demi finale vous avez vu le
résultat le résultat bien votre pire
mais avec sophie pierre naquin main de
dieu ouais bah ce serait ça c'est xavier
de fontenay dans ce serait qui elle pire
de tout ça serait ce lié avec qu on
apprendrait que
qu'il a déjà quelqu'un
vous est arrivé ça déjà qui t'a fait
cela c'est un mec de la télé ça dans la
1re étape
non mais si basse leur hausse à mèze un
mec de la télé non mais très connu
je peux pire souvenir
pierre de gauche au
sénat
comme ça dans lequel le l'hôtel
campanile accompagné forte non non non
un truc bon c'est pas vraiment pire mais
elle l'événement on se demande qu'est ce
qu'il fait là quoi c'était comme un
salon se pacsant dans l'agriculture mais
une fois le storm pirelli au second
que des toute sa vie non mais on était
dans la boue il faisait super froid et
au milieu des vaches c'est sa
progression voilà abandonner
votre pire expérience homosexuelle
y en a pas ça tout est réussi mais je
peux en a pas et donc ça veut dire votre
pire moment avec geneviève de fontenay
bassesse était en fait on n'était pas
ensemble mais c'est ce qui s'est passé
par après la sortie du livre tout ce qui
a été dit est un moment assez dur à
vivre le moment le plus moyen de toute
ta carrière maintenant
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu